de l'autre côté de la frontière en
territoire russe tôt ce matin un dépôt
de munitions étaient en flammes dans la
ville de belgorod la russie a déjà
accusé à plusieurs reprises ces
dernières semaines kiev de mener des
frappes sur son territoire depuis le
début de la semaine la transnistrie
région séparatiste pro russe de moldavie
fait elle aussi état d'explosions sur
son sol ce matin encore les autorités
locales affirment que des tirs en
provenance d'ukraine ont visé dans la
nuit un dépôt de munitions le ministère
de l'intérieur de transnistrie annonce
aussi avoir repéré des drones lancé
depuis l'ukraine on va en parler avec
vous gauthier rybinski bonjour vous êtes
chroniqueur internationale sur france 24
doit-on craindre une extension de ce
conflit ukrainien au delà de ses
frontières
oui parce que même si le territoire de
la transnistrie est beaucoup plus petit
que lucas nous que même le donbass il y
à un précédent en ce qui le concerne et
un précédent aussi de historique c'est à
dire que le kremlin favorise la même
réflexion et la même torsion de
l'histoire on va regarder ça sur sur la
carte vous avez voilà alors la
transnistrie elle se situe exactement
[Musique]
voilà donc la transnistrie c'est ce
petit territoire qui est peuplées de
russes de russophones disons qu'ils ne
sont pas tous d'ailleurs proclame un et
en bordure de la moldavie donc ça veut
dire que en termes de droit
international cela appartient à la
moldavie le conflit qui dure depuis à
peu près 30 ans 30 ans ou des
séparatistes qui ont pris le pouvoir
essaye de se rattacher à la russie et
n'y arrive pas la moldavie elle
considère évidemment c'est son
territoire et je vous disais qu'il y
avait une torsion historique c'est que
les russes transnistrie considère que
cette appartenance à la moldavie et
comme s'ils appartenaient à la roumanie
et que dans l'histoire la roumanie de la
deuxième guerre mondiale avait un régime
fasciste pro nazi vous voyez on y
revient c'est à dire le régime pro
fasciste a fait 75 ans qu'il n'y en a
plus donc voilà le la pomme de discorde
et il est évident que le prétexte est le
m et donc on peut craindre que les
causes et que les effets soient
également les mêmes donc voilà ce qu'est
la transnistrie elle est tout à fait
c'est un voyage dans le passé la
transnistrie s'éteint c'est un endroit
c'est une région qui a encore les
statues de lénine en plein milieu de
tiraspol sa capitale qui est tout à fait
tourner vers ce qui était le passé
communiste de l'urss